[Música]
boa noite galera tudo bem eu tô aqui pra
falar pra vocês sobre como eu acredito
que a comunicação pode transformar o
mundo num lugar muito melhor e eu sei
que é bem fora de acreditar nisso uma
vez que a propaganda uma das principais
ferramentas desse capitalismo exagerado
que trouxe o mundo com o status que ele
está hoje
mas acredito tanto que eu vou falar pra
vocês tanto que o desafiar o desafio até
o mais pessimista de vocês para uma
conversa porque o parto de um princípio
básico de que lá no fundo lá no fundo a
gente não quer que o mundo inteiro se
exploda beleza
quando comecei a trabalhar com
propaganda há dez anos atrás eu
compreendi rapidamente que eu estava
trabalhando construindo marcas que
visavam unicamente o lucro a definição
de sucesso das organizações é o dinheiro
e eu percebi que a responsabilidade
social de uma organização é o mínimo
possível para que ela conquiste um selo
de responsabilidade social
quer dizer basicamente é que ao invés de
mudarem a forma do refrigerante porque
ele faz mal para as pessoas
eles investem institutos fundações
um dos projetos sociais basicamente para
melhorar ainda mais o cenário a
indústria criativa indústria da
comunicação é principalmente agências de
propaganda escritórios de comunicação
que está é onde estão grande maioria das
pessoas que trabalham com construção de
marca hoje tá cheio de gente pensando
negócio tempo inteiro então a gente vê
publicitários querendo ganhar prêmio
para conseguir salários melhores
a gente vê agências querendo vender mais
mídia para conseguir dinheiro através da
bonificação ea gente vê o marketing do
cliente queremos resultados a curto
prazo porque isso precisa ficar
crescimento em números não engajamento
da comunidade ou felicidade é muito
louco entender esse cenário dessa forma
e talvez essa por entender dessa forma
que a gente consiga ver porque muitos
profissionais de comunicação estão
saindo no nosso mercado
ah eu percebi muito rápido o que faltava
profundidade nas promessas
institucionais das marcas que estava
construindo o discurso pelo discurso já
não fazia mais sentido
aí começou a aparecer histórias daquele
suco de laranja falou que as suas
laranjas eram especiais porque elas eram
colhidas lá na fazenda do vôo ou sei lá
das quantas
começou a surgir histórias do sorvete
que era feito pelo outro vovô senhoras
quantos desde a época da guerra e essas
histórias de marketing em falsas é que
nos provam que pensar unicamente no
discurso hoje não faz mais sentido
as pessoas vão saber a verdade elas
vamos saber que a laranja que vai ter um
suco vai pra onde vai pra todos os
outros cincos das outras organizações
também momento é essa transparência que
acontece hoje pra mim é o primeiro
indício de porque a gente pode sim
acreditar que a gente tem como construir
comunidades melhores
em 2014 eu fui convidado a empreender
show de chi chi chi já tinha sido criada
era um espaço de intervenções urbanas
construído por dois amigos meus
publicitários igualmente insatisfeitos
com o mercado com o objetivo de tirar a
idéia do papel ideia simples idéias
rápidas e das fáceis e desce todo mundo
poderia fazer
idéias como que o ônibus passa aqui que
se propôs a analisar as paradas de
ônibus de porto alegre de forma
colaborativa e acabou aparecendo em mais
de 30 cidades
idéias como paraíso do golfe que a gente
jogou o fino os buracos das ruas de
porto alegre para chamar a atenção na
quantidade de buracos que tinha na rua
ea prefeitura tapou vários desses
buracos não todos e também não duram
para sempre mas as pessoas começaram a
perceber isso
idéias como um simples adesivo de
combate ao fumo que girou o mundo
inteiro foi para tem um blog russo e nos
trouxe reputação no mercado criativo e
10 como cadeiraço
chamou a atenção das pessoas convidou
ela se mobilizou para que elas fossem
até as ruas preocupar a cidade de fato
mostrando para a prefeitura que se
tivesse bancos a gente sentaria idéias
que perguntam para as pessoas o que elas
acham que a sociedade precisa e tenta
conversar sobre isso e quando a gente
olha para trás e aprendi sobre o que a
gente estava fazendo a gente consegue
entender que existe um padrão nessas
idéias é diferente do que o mercado
criativo entrega essas idéias fazem
gente para a rua de fato usar o spray
site tirar a bunda da cadeira e viver de
fato a cidade que a gente mora que a
gente vive participar da nossa
comunidade e nada mais gratificante do
que a gente conseguir ver a
transformação na prática
eu me apaixonei pelas idéias simples
replicáveis idéias que começaram a
aparecer no brasil inteiro e que mesmo
que a gente planejar se não teria a
menor possibilidade de isso realmente
teu alcance que teve sempre ideias que
fosse um adesivo em cartaz uma placa um
estêncil e 10 que todo mundo poderia
baixar fazer na sociedade desce todo
mundo poderia criar e fazer nossa cidade
totalmente aberta simples assim e eu
aprendi algumas coisas
a primeira delas é que eu aprendi que a
melhor forma de reclamar de alguma coisa
é fazendo alguma coisa então não adianta
a gente ficar falando falando falando o
tempo inteiro reclamando tem que ir pra
rua e colocar a mão na massa assim a
gente ganha mais propriedade sobre o
assunto
eu aprendi que o humor que tem poder
transformador pode ser usado para falar
sobre o impacto social
não é porque a gente fala sobre o
impacto social que a gente tem que fazer
isso de um jeito chato ou que deixe todo
mundo triste eu aprendi que existe só no
domingo de manhã eu amo dormir não sei
vocês eu amo dormir e para mim sempre
foi muito difícil entender que existe um
período de no domingo de manhã
mas se a grande verdade é que isto
realmente se importa com alguma coisa
o domingo de manhã passa a ser uma
excelente oportunidade para que eu faça
algo de fato
eu já tive essa ideia antes
quantos de vocês já falaram isso
enquanto vocês já pensaram nisso
pra mim essa frase deixou parou de fazer
sentido quando eu percebi que todo mundo
tem ideias sobretudo o tempo inteiro
para qualquer problema todo mundo tem
800 idéias e aí o entende que o que vale
mesmo é a idéia é ação execução é ir lá
e fazer alguma coisa ideia boa idéia de
sucesso idéia que deixe todo mundo feliz
a idéia é executada e para falar a
verdade não tem nem como ter o controle
do impacto de uma idéia dessas então
construa narrativa e abra mão desse
controle
pra mim hoje idéia de impacto a minha
definição de sucesso é impactar a vida
de uma pessoa
todas as ações precisam de um envelope
publicitário as ações que mostrei aqui
pra você seu posicionamento delas foram
que foi o que construiu a reputação do
egito por exemplo e essa reputação ea
precisa de calma mas vocês precisam de
um nome de um conceito de um tom e
linguagem
elas precisam de um rótulo publicitário
e essas ações que mostrei que tiveram
todo esse penso trouxeram reputação pra
gente e essa reputação trouxe
curiosidade das pessoas físicas e
jurídicas no que a gente estava fazendo
e trouxe confiança para nós pensar eu
tem coisa aí dá pra continuar fazendo
isso
quando você tem uma boa reputação como
um gatinho é as coisas começam a
acontecer as conexões começam a aparecer
pra você
as pessoas nem sabem o que você faz mas
elas parecem amar muito o que você faz
aí você é chamado pra pensar evento
construir comunicação interna construir
propósito é intervenção urbana
participar de palestras workshops e dá
um encontro como esse
e aí eu estava ali oito anos depois de
ter começado a trabalhar com propaganda
tocando um negócio de comunicação que
não era bem uma parada de agência online
agência promocional a agência online era
impacto social
eu só sabia disso porque o propósito
estava muito bem definido
a gente acredita que a comunicação das
principais ferramentas para a gente
transformar o mundo
e aí eu finalmente entendi que eu podia
a que aquele sistema que estava sendo
usado sem propósito até então para
construir marcas que liderem a
transformação que o mundo precisa hoje
e aí eu fui atrás de como as
organizações de fato nasceram será que
elas sempre nunca se importaram com o
mundo ninguém nunca falou sobre isso
antes como elas deveriam se importar e
basicamente uma pesquisa rápida no
google responde pra vocês mas para
contextualizar as organizações a uma
marca um negócio é um grupo de pessoas
que trabalham com os mesmos objetivos
um deles é o lucro
as organizações do jeito que a gente
conhece hoje nasceram na era industrial
o nome shows que diz que as organizações
eram grupos licenciados pelo governo por
uma tarefa específica como erguer uma
ponte por exemplo elas eram altamente
reguladas pelo estado quanto tempo elas
iam durar
quem eram os sócios qual o valor do
capital e elas faziam aquilo e ao não
fazer um nada mais do que aquilo que os
sócios não poderiam ser sócios de outras
organizações e poderiam sim ser
responsabilizados por qualquer problema
que desce com a ponte por exemplo e
chegar os advogados
nada contra os advogados mas chegaram à
corte suprema dos estados unidos para
remover algumas restrições que existiam
com as corporações usando a 14ª emenda
como justificativa a 14ª emenda diz um
trecho dela que ninguém pode tirar
propriedade a vida ea liberdade de uma
pessoa sem um processo jurídico adequado
a 14ª emenda que foi criado para
proteger os escravos recém libertados
foi usado pelos advogados para remover
algumas restrições das organizações com
a justificativa de que ninguém pode
tirar a propriedade à vida liberdade uma
pessoa sem um processo jurídico adequado
nós somos uma pessoa uma pessoa jurídica
e ainda assim esse termo que a gente usa
até hoje quando vai abrir uma empresa
eu acho que todo mundo deve se perguntar
e eu comecei a me perguntar isso é não
tem problema nenhum você falar que é uma
pessoa com corda talvez seja uma boa
porém se você
uma pessoa que tipo de pessoa você então
imagine o cenário aqui comigo
coloque essa pessoa que nasceu dessa
forma sem noções éticas e sentimentos em
uma rede onde está todo mundo falando
sobre tudo o tempo inteiro
coloque essa marca numa rede social que
acontece
ela é uma pessoa que a gente fica mega
orgulhosos de estar conectado por que
ela está fazendo muito bem para a
comunidade em que está inserida coisas
que nós devemos fazer a gente olha e
fala back legal está fazendo isso ou ela
fica falando dos produtos dela o tempo
inteiro
a gente está vivendo uma era de
transição de mídia de massa para a massa
de mídia o que quer dizer que pensar em
um discurso e colocar ele nos veículos
para atingir as massas já não funciona
mais com a mesma eficiência então hoje
pessoas e marcas dividem espaços nossas
times online e você está na sua timeline
a primeira foto que aparece é dos seus
amigos que fizeram uma festa não me
convidaram e aí você vai lá dá um like
falou pô eu ter me convidado para um
pouco mais sua família parece seu
sobrinho aquelas pessoas que estão que
faz tempo que você não vê porque você
mora longe você coloca uma meia e fala
saudade de vocês vai falar um pouquinho
mais nenhum tênis
né família festa amigos tênis
não faz muito sentido quando esse
entendimento de como isso é um bom
momento para travar o edifício quando
esse entendimento de como as marcas
podem sim participar do desenvolvimento
sustentável do mundo ajudando e
favorecendo esse tipo de ação quando
isso acontece de fato aquela
insatisfação para usar seu poder
criativo para construir algo totalmente
sem propósito
finalmente começa a ter fim agora que
deveria explodir sob as marcas que
querem construir um mundo melhor hoje
elas falam basicamente na sua
comunicação sobre a história das pessoas
que fazem parte dessa comunidade uma
marca é uma pessoa ligada por outras
pessoas assim como todo mundo aqui está
ela talvez não tenha tantos grupos de
ódio zap que nem gente mas ela tem
comunidade com o colaborador comunidade
com parceiro estratégico e com clientes
então não adianta mais não faz mais
sentido a gente está usando foto de uma
de bank ou criando vídeos institucionais
lindíssimos onde a gente contrata
pessoas prato aparecendo ser aquilo que
a gente quer que pensem que a gente é de
fato as marcas hoje podem assumir
protagonismo de transformação cultural
que o mundo inteiro precisa não só o
brasil podem fazer parte do movimento
das bikes e colocar abaixo pelo país
inteiro por exemplo podem eliminar todas
aquelas plásticas da sua rede de lojas
incentivar todo mundo a fazer a mesma
coisa
as marcas podem atuar como plataforma
criando um ambiente para que a conexão
entre as pessoas os cidadãos cidadãos e
as causas
finalmente aconteceu criando um ambiente
para que protagonistas da mudança que a
gente precisa de fato apareçam
elas podem ser curadora de conteúdo
trazendo para a conversa assunto que a
gente ainda precisa resolver a gente
ainda precisa falar de aborto igualdade
de gênero preconceito racial legalização
das drogas
olha quanta coisa incrível quem trabalha
com comunicação pode fazer hoje e é isso
que me motiva construir pessoas marcas
consciência que falem sobre o assunto
que a gente fala com as nossas famílias
que falem sobre assuntos que a gente
fala com os nossos amigos nas nossas
horas de conversa que entendam o mundo
que elas estão entrando e as
responsabilidades que trás disso
hoje tudo é comunicação não só o que tu
faz o que tu diz que faz mas também o
que você deixe de fazer por isso que a
gente sabe que a rede de lojas eliminou
sacolas plásticas
ela contou essa transparência ou brigas
marcas as pessoas a se tornarem mais
transparentes para que a gente veja -
histórias de marketing falsas
eu adoro acreditar que a gente tem tudo
pra ver um mundo melhor acontecendo
aquele pode finalmente deixar de ser
utopia e eu acho que esse é o tesão que
trabalha a comunicação tem que ter hoje
tá eu quero muito ver campanhas com mais
velhos da colaboração mas colaboração
mesmo não chega porque o principal
concorrente falando cara peguei o meu
melhor sanduíche aqui com o teu melhor
mesclei identidade visual mais e essa o
site para vender mais e é essa o a loja
vai vender mais e esses na colaboração
colaboração isso quer colaborar mesmo
chama as pessoas para o processo quer
mais engajamento da cidade chama cidadão
para conversas que é mais engajamento da
sua turma chama as pessoas para falar
sobre isso
foi assim que a gente analisou algumas
ruas de porto alegre por exemplo que não
tinha uma plaquinha com o nome da rua a
gente mapeou essas ruas chegou até um
colégio parceiro nosso com o nome das
ruas e junto com as crianças da 3ª série
a gente construiu que a gente mude se
essa rua fosse minha
outra coisa que eu sempre senti falta
foi a sensibilidade das pessoas que
trabalham com comunicação ninguém não se
faz a ninguém faz uma simples pergunta
será que essa comunicação pode ofender
alguém
a gente acaba vendo em carnaval
campanhas que incentivam o estupro
a gente ainda vê campanhas que comparam
a filmagem não consensual ea divulgação
de vídeos íntimos com simples dor de
cabeça
o quanto as pessoas têm nesse processo
que ainda não entenderam que só precisam
fazer uma simples reflexão será que essa
comunicação pode ofender alguém
enfim pessoal essas estratégias de
comunicação de negócios que eu trago pra
se encontra hoje eu acredito que eles
podem ajudar a gente a construir um
mundo mais transparente e colaborativa e
consciente
a gente não pode esquecer que uma marca
é uma pessoa criada por outras pessoas
assim como todo mundo aqui então se
existem marcas que hoje não querem
ajudar o mundo a se tornar um lugar
melhor
talvez seja porque elas não querem mesmo
o porquê as pessoas que estão no
processo ainda não entender o seu papel
na comunidade
então eu convido todos vocês todos vocês
mesmo até quem não é da área de
comunicação a participarem do mundo que
vocês vivem hoje transformando em um
lugar mais transparente mais
colaborativo mais consciente mais
sustentável usando um poder que nasce
com todo mundo aqui
a comunicação a transformação está nas
nossas mãos
portugal muito obrigado